[موسيقى]
شهر شوال هو شهر العاشر من شهور السنه
الهجريه وهي سنه قمريه تعتمد على رؤيه
الهلال في شهورها وكان يقع في موسم الحرب
وقت التسميه ولهذا كانت البان الابل تشول
اي تنقص وقيل لان الناقه كانت تشول بذيلها
فلا يضعها الجمل ولهذا العرب كانوا
يتشائمون من الزواج خلال هذا الشهر ومع
مجيء الاسلامي ابطل عليهم هذا فتزوج النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم عائشه في شهر شوال من
السنه الاولى للهجره وهو شهر الذي يحتوي
على اشهر يوم واعظم سته ايام في السنه من
صام رمضان ثم اتبعه سته من شوال كان كصيام
الدهر
لا تنسوا صيام الست من شوال
[تصفيق]
وشهري شوال لهذه السنه في اوله اجواء
لطيفه بوجه عام ومن منتصفه تبدا درجات
الحراره بالارتفاع التدريجي تباعا مع مرور
الايام وبعد 60 يوما نعيش اطول نهر واقصر
ليالي السنه على الاطلاق وهو موسم حر
الانصراف الذي يقال فيه لا حر الا بعد
الانصراف
[موسيقى]